أعني أن هذا مجرد فيديو رائع
قد تعتقد أن هذا كان مشهدًا من
برنامج Netflix الذي تعرضه إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA)، حيث ترى
القوات الخاصة الإسرائيلية تدخل مستشفى في
مدينة جانين بالضفة الغربية المحتلة، حيث يوجد
حوالي عشرة من قوات الكوماندوز متنكرين في زي
مدنيين بالإضافة إلى بعض الطواقم الطبية.
منهم نساء محجبات
وقتلوا ثلاثة مسلحين فلسطينيين
تتفق حماس وإسرائيل على أن
الأفراد الذين قتلوا في هذه
الحالة هم بالفعل
مسلحين فلسطينيين يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنهم
مرتبطون بها وكذلك
الجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطيني أه
ويقولون  أنهم متورطون في
هجمات على القوات الإسرائيلية بالإضافة إلى
اقتباس يروج لنشاط إرهابي كبير
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي
إنهم كانوا مختبئين في ذلك المستشفى عندما
قُتلوا أه المستشفى من
جانبه يقول أن واحدًا على الأقل من الرجال
كان يتلقى العلاج
لإصاباته